. Let's go to our caller from the 774 area
code 7 7 4 is risky.
It's often a local color and sometimes it
goes well.
Sometimes it goes not so well.
And they are we still on the.
That to me is the Gallia from was the good
to be here.
What's the what's going on now?
Hey, I'm not doing too good, to be honest,
buddy.
I can barely hear you, my friend is there.
So you might actually need you to speak up
a little bit.
David.
I'm here, buddy.
But I'm telling you this blood on the streets
and I'm trying to be careful.
I'm not trying to be too loud.
OK, Dave.
Yes.
OK, listen.
I am a socialist.
I don't like social.
I'd like socialism.
Or is this pet producer friend again from
a different numbering?
Are we not turning into anti-social?
That's the whole thing.
Oh, you hung up.
OK.
I think that's Pat's friend who just likes
to make puns on the term socialism.
It's really odd.